jimmy butler who's on fire one-on-one
they switch
everybody out of the way allow me to
have this dance and i'm not letting you
off the hook
gets to his spot elevates continues
reminds me of
as a kid watching ali frazier going into
round
15. both guys unbelievably fatigued euro
we saw it earlier with duncan just
dropping it off because of the attention
that they get
coming off that's what i'm talking about
this is a switch quite how it's a great
defender but not against perimeter guys
and you have to win that match-up
playing a little bit but good hesitation
dribble shoots off the wrong foot
jimmy butler has only taken two shots he
said he needed to shoot more to score
more
that's his first field goal he hit a
bunch of free throws
the shot making of lebron james robinson
to butler
butler goes inside and banks at home
that's what butler
said that they needed to do before they
gave me a bill walton versus memphis
in the final four i think it was 20 for
21.
as butler comes back no he's 21 for 22.
right
he is truly an extension of the coach on
the court his bind
he's playing chess while everybody else
is playing checkers and his ability to
make plays
oh jimmy butler all right to the bucket
points nine assists nine rebounds misses
the free throw and the lakers with the
early lead
jimmy butler drives and finishes was
13 assists to career high form in game
two then with the seal down the other
end they throw it ahead to butler and
butler throws it down
and frank vogel calls timeout that your
defense creates some offense here
the deflection from behind by butler
leads to a butler dunk
and an eight-point lead twice as many
turnovers as they have field goals right
now
butler drives spins goes right to the
rim and gets it to fall jimmy butler now
six points three assists
it's a 20 to nine lead for miami i
wouldn't
this is not an old fat by the way this
is a great play by butler but that
charge was not your old-fashioned nbhr
on this lake of defense get to your spot
and think score
switching dunkin robinson on lebron
tonight he's showing
and then getting back to his initial man
butler drives all sweet fake from jimmy
butler turns and scores salute pro
and can impact the game in a variety of
ways gives you a chance to win
with everything he does on the floor and
off the court one of the smartest
players who's played in the nba
butler tough fall away shot is good does
along with kelly olynyk exceptional
handing off and faking handle
nice feet inside butler to crowder they
have connected several times now
guarding butler
hiro sets the screen caldwell pope picks
him up one on one
butler backs in backs in that full away
shot is up and good
34 for butler it's an eight-point lead
just gets mar markeith morris back
paddling
takes a bump and finishes it
120 remaining butler says give me the
ball
butler the drive the runner he banks it
in oh what a masterpiece from jimmy
butler
defended by davis and howard so okay now
it's time to spread the floor and make a
play
i'm not letting these guys off the hook
if i'm jimmy butler it's just a
continuation
of game three but they have to take away
his right miami heat had 52 points in
the paint
tonight including that that's 26 halfway
home give the lakers credit but jimmy
butler
make the proper adjustments this is what
we must eat on the other end
robinson sets a solid screen eliminates
the help
eliminates the ability for davis to get
back into the picture in traffic
screen roll catches it immediately sees
crowder
on point pass that's great offense and a
great pass from butler
much shorter shot clock winding down
butler gets in the paint that mid-range
jumper is good
hands off to hero right back to butler
butler defended well but
overcomes marquis morris pass inside
davis deflects it davis fouls and butler
once again two points six
assists six rebounds he's seven of ten
from the field
and hits that as the shot clock expires
meanwhile lebron james 21 points two
quarters complete here in game five the
heat trying to keep their season alive
up by four gets it back to butler quick
jumper jimmy butler and he knocks it
down as the shot glock expires back to
one
howard now guarding butler butler step
back jumper that's good
oh wow
that to me is the definition whether
it's intentional or not and that's not
part of it
third quarter as this presentation of
the nba finals will continue
after this message and a word from our
abc stations
butler one on one with markeith morris
butler
drives falling away got it again
good ball denial from caldwell pope and
obayo a couple of dribbles
nice feed inside the butler butler
changes layup
count it and the foul butler found an
angle
drew some contact and a chance for a
three-point play i mean
it's it's a grind the lakers are into
them
[Applause]
clearly the contact underneath and
butler gets the back to have had a a
terrific
connection on the floor all season james
is one of
caruso's biggest fans as butler goes in
and jimmy butler who has been
to say the least sensational with the
clippers and the nuggets and the rockets
even
the eight-seated blazers were picked by
some to upset the lakers in the first
round